my first cat 2 was on my 18th birthday
then came patches and then came a lot
more like a lot of teenagers I suffered
from depression and the best part about
being a teenager was patches because she
was always there I would walk in the
house after like doing whatever I was
some bad if I was doing drugs or if I
was out late or if I was partying or
whatever and she would just give me the
same look every time like oh hey I'm so
glad you're homeless let's hang out and
cuddle and it was like consistent across
the board always would happen and that
was really awesome because I needed that
and I had her for about 14 years and I
just knew I had to memorialize her with
a tattoo so she's now on my arm and with
me forever
in the tattoo industry cat art feline
art is really popular right now and more
popular than I've ever noticed I always
knew from ever since I started seeing
tattoos up people loved to memorialize
their pets and I have them myself so I
don't know it was natural to do them the
cat tooth thing really started after I
did the cat kitty in a teacup on my
husband's leg I started to paint cats
and then I got commissioned to do some
cat art and then I got requests to do
another cat too and and then it's just
these things happen you know they they
they spiral wants to do something that
somebody thinks is great they get it and
then they tell their friends and the
friend gets it and then another friend
gets it and and pretty soon you have a
whole portfolio full of cat ooze
about a year
but I found you online I don't I don't
remember everything yeah I'm just
looking around
yeah I think you might have coined that
term people are constantly asking me for
them and I am never tired of doing them
he'll forever be grateful for anybody
who lets me tattoo their pet on them
because I know how much it means and I
really like to be able to share that
with them because they usually tell me
their story of how awesome their cat is
or how awesome their cat was and I then
can do the same about patches and my
cats know
I think it turned out amazing like
yeah but partially said I'm partially
interpreting yes the top the top third
I'm extrapolating but I'm gonna assume a
lot of them are really special and a lot
of them some of them were just super fun
and the person gets a cat tattoo because
they just want something that feels good
that's what I love about tattooing you
don't have to get a tattoo that's so
super meaningful and it's like so
serious sometimes it just makes you feel
good when you look at it when I'm not
tattooing I'm drawing and I'm painting
and I'm focusing on unlearning new
techniques and and how to improve a lot
of times there's deadlines because
you're you're commissioned for things
you're commissioned for paintings or
you're commissioned to do a tattoo so
you have to draw the design for the
tattoo and that could be stressful so
the best the best part about having the
cats around is you know if I'm just
freaking out like in and I'm I'm over
here painting and dummy over there in
the corner sleeping I just I don't even
need to touch him I can just look at him
for a minute and take a breath and go
people are very surprised when they hear
I only have two cats because they hear
me talking about cats and they see my
art and they're like she must have like
14 cats and no I mean I have to I think
two is a great number and I think that's
what's changed the typical cat lady from
what it was used to be one one woman
alone with like 20 cats and now it's
like no it's it's anybody you're in a
relationship or you're single or you
have a roommate and you have a cat a cat
or two cats maybe you know it's not like
this big thing
Oh to view cat fur day just a day
forever nine years old